i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
where the fear is gone
only i will remain when i i think that
uh it's a novel that uh
stayed with me for almost 40 years and
every every time i read it there was
something different in it according to
where i was in life you know where and
my development as a human being that
it's a that's our masterpiece
it is is that every time you read it you
find something new and it's so rich and
so dense but i was at the beginning as a
as a boy
i think that i was deeply moved by
paul's journey where a boy finds
his identity uh being in contact with
another culture that is not afraid of
being with a another culture is is
instead he embrace uh the other culture
there's no real culture shock i mean
he's just like
uh blending and then finding his
identity and finally finding peace being
in contact with other people that are
not from his background you know there's
something very beautiful to think that
there's a strain into being different
and embracing another culture
and then there was also this love for
frank herbert for biology the way
biology is part of uh is at the very art
of of the novel and and
how he took that this so seriously and
and uh
there's also this beautiful idea of the
benedict that are uh
women that can channel
the past voice and paul will have that
power to to to be in contact with the
memories of the past and that has an
idea that i thought was very powerful
because he has to find his own freedom
with all this past house this genetic
heritage is his education heritage he
has to find a way to be himself and and
to get rid of these ghosts and and in
order to find his true freedom and and
and becoming a real adult in the world
and i thought that was really
powerful ideas when i read it at first
you have proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
timothy is one of the best if not the
best actor of his generation is like
when you
need someone that will be the central
figure of a movie like doom you need
someone that will be able to
add that weight on his shoulder and
carry the movie on the shoulder and
paul's journey is kind of complex that
it's multi-layered that's why i had i
needed someone that will have and the
talent and the the sensibility and the
intelligence to be to totally understand
what the character they required and
timothy is is a brilliant very very very
mature young man you sometimes when you
speak with timothy you feel that you
speak with someone that is
three times his age i mean he has like a
deep old soul
and someone who has a deep old soul
and looks 14 to 15 years old is polar
trees you know so it's like and also
timothy has something very aristocratic
at the end of the day still he's a
prince there's a beautiful uh
something in his features that fits
totally the part and and looked like the
description and
he had the charisma of a rock star and
we have to believe that this character
one day will lead an army will lead the
planet and and and uh
well um i needed that charisma he's he's
a
the camera just love him dreams make
good stories
but everything important happens when
we're awake oh there's a lot of uh i
will say that that's my deep joy about
the movie is that there's a lot of
moments that uh i'm like
that's close what uh uh
i would say that the at first the
arrival of the ninja series on kaladan
and then the gamja bar scene i was like
ouch that's pretty close oh i i was uh
dreaming about it and then
everything in the desert all the desert
scenes are pretty close to what i
envisioned
as a kid yeah
this is why you
kill them all
the thing is that ants and i both agreed
that the the score should be very
feminine because from it was one of my
goal was to make sure
that the female power of the novel what
would feel like a female
empowerment or i don't know that the the
the strength of the woman the female
strength that is in the novel will be up
front in the in the movie because i i
love the miniature series yeah too much
and and then lady jessica is one of my
favorite characters there was also the
will to
try to create a score that will fill
from another world a alien score using
instruments that have not been here
before
with some rhythms that are away from
what we've heard before or that that
will create a feeling of alien and also
more importantly hans like me is a
hardcore fan of the novel and we knew
that
music could be of a big it could be a
massive
tool to help us to understand what are
the characters thinking what are the
they're feeling where do they stand and
that the music was used as a
counterpoint to
bring this idea that we have like access
to some kind of
the inner world because the word the
novel is about a lot about what the
characters are thinking and their
strategy in order to survive and and or
to manipulate somebody else but we are
always in presence of their thought
which we don't have in the movie but we
can have a clue the hint of that through
music
that i delayed the base the the basic of
the world it's done now say i don't have
to explain that most of the world the
basic is explained so now i can just
have fun with cinema
that's what i will say is that uh
i think that if ever such a thing
happens as part two it's gonna be a
cinematic party i mean that's not the
right word i apologize i will say it's
it's gonna be a cinematic blast for me i
think that i how could that uh
create something much more
built into a cinematic
action and that
yeah slimmer less stalking
[Music]
you